you have any uh opinions on 2024
elections like who you foresee uh being
at the helm who who has a shot what are
your thoughts on the climate today
because what happened this week which is
kind of a every comedian's dream come
true both sides
had Declassified documents and now the
side
who bashed the other side the
president's uh backing up his Corvette
and the classified documents are on the
back Peter Ducey asked the question
saying what was that all about why is
there classified documents in your
garage it says I always lock my garage
he's like what do you mean you lock your
garage well the funny thing is to me
this is the managerial class in
government striking again right Merrick
Garland looks at a U.S president the
same way that Anthony fauci looks at
most citizens shut up sit down and do
what you're told okay Joe Biden's use
has passed well guess what now the leaks
begin now the Insiders turn on him and
they're going to dispose of him the same
way the same institutions tried to
dispose of President Trump okay it's
like Jim Comey teaching Hillary Clinton
a lesson well guess what he'll teach
Donald Trump a lesson this is the this
is the real threat to democracy is that
technocratic bureaucratic managerial
class and the illusion that we live in
today the biggest illusion in America
today
is that the people who we elect to run
the government are the people who
actually run the government they do not
okay and I think that the top of an
agenda for I think for the GOP is more
likely today may as well be the
Democratic party for all I care needs to
be to replace the Civil Service
protections that stop a U.S president
from being able to fire the people who
report to him
to convert those to Sunset Clauses
instead and say you know what if you're
the U.S president you can't serve in
this country can't serve in that
position in this country for more than
eight years I don't think most federal
employees should be in their positions
for more than eight years either that's
how you actually drain the so-called
swamp and I think that that's not a
republican agenda or Democratic agenda I
think it is a pro-constitutional
democratic Integrity agenda you think
Kevin McCarthy is swamp
you know I I the elected officials
bother me less to be honest with you
because they're still backstopped by
public accountability he's got to get
elected every two years he's accountable
to the public what bothers me and you
know what I don't I don't I'm not as big
on this um I mean I don't care as much
about like term limits we can talk about
that honestly Cloud favorite term limits
but where I think the real action is is
sunset Clauses for the people who work
in those bureaucracies without
governmental accountability and you ask
about 2024 well I'll tell you this
I think Republicans in particular are
too fixated on the question of who
instead of asking the question of what
as in what does it actually mean to be a
conservative or what does it actually
mean to be an American and and I picked
the Republicans because you know
presumably
um you have you have an incumbent
president who we'll see how long this
last could run
I think the rebelling party is obsessed
too much on the who too much on the
biographical aspect of this and not
enough on defining what it is it wants
to stand for and you know if I uh if I
have something to say about it you know
I care about advancing that agenda so
we'll talk over the next few months yeah
it's going to be interesting to see what
happens you have any uh political uh uh
aspirations long term or no
I think that aspirations would be the
wrong way to say it I think I have
frustrations
I did think about running for the U.S
Senate in 2022 in for the 2022 seat in
Ohio when it opened up in early 21. I
def I decided that being one of a
hundred was not the right setting for me
I I think it's really important that
good people fill that role but for me I
got a good piece of advice which is if
you want to interview for a job which is
what you're doing if you're running a
campaign make sure you actually want the
job and that you think you'd be
passionate about doing that job and
being one of a hundred people pretending
to pass laws when in fact just trying to
get on Fox news or MSNBC at night that
didn't appeal to me and I think that's
what many people in that seat are doing
today
so I won't run for the Senate um but
beyond that so meaning are you more of a
one of a hundred guy one of 50 guy or
one of one guy
I think I met my best when I can be one
of one guy that actually gets something
done but but I couldn't do it if your
hands are tied by the people who
effectively work underneath you because
I haven't run a company I'll tell you if
you can't fire somebody they don't
actually work for you I've done deals in
Japan in Japan I've talked to CEOs where
they will tell you they literally can't
fire a guy who works for them so they'll
tell him the Pharma companies included
they'll tell them to change the projects
they're working on the employee will not
okay go back three months later the
employee's doing exactly what he was
supposed to what he was doing before
why because what the CEO does says
doesn't matter if you can't be fired for
deviating from that mandate and that's
what we need to fix in our federal
government is I don't care if it's a
Democrat or Republican I at least want
the people who we elect the person who
we elect to occupy that seat to actually
run the executive branches you know what
would be crazy is that the case today
there was a guy imagine a world where a
guy who ran a show where he was famous
for firing people became a president
imagine that if only yeah and then now
imagine that I mean
do you think there's any chance he'll be
back in there we think it's going to be
more descentes
I don't believe in a dual Choice menu
you're not an in and out guy I'm not I
don't believe in just two choices uh you
know on any menu so give us a third
choice let's let's let the year unfold
why don't we
is there a third choice you would think
like is there anybody else that would be
their third choice now we're going back
too much on this it's going back to the
problem that I said too much discussion
of The Who and not enough discussion but
what is what I actually care about I get
that but that's that's kind of a uh on
to to fix the what right now with what
happened this last week where uh I agree
with you not it's not a uh
you saw what Matt Gates happened with
those guys were you know Kevin McCarthy
thought the Red Wave was going to get
him to say I don't need anybody from
Trump's Camp I can do whatever I want to
do you guys go talk whatever you I want
to get so many different you know the
red wave that you guys can't even say
nothing I don't need your signatures I
don't need your votes [ __ ] change he
kind of needs their help a lot
so it's in a different place where they
kind of have to work together or else
the other side could potentially uh fire
this guy named Joe Biden and bring this
other guy named Gavin I don't know if
you know this other guy named Gavin who
uh likes to go to The French Laundry a
lot without yeah so he's uh making sure
that everyone else doesn't yeah that's
the key part of it he's seeming to be
their Superstar so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]